senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
is blasting a fellow republican
congresswoman that's marjorie taylor
greene for her record of endorsing a
series of conspiracy theories
mcconnell did not mention her by name
but said in a statement loony lies and
conspiracy theories are cancer for the
republican party and our country
somebody who suggested that perhaps no
airplane hit the pentagon on 9 11
that horrifying school shootings were
pre-staged and that the clintons crashed
jfk junior's airplane
is not living in reality this has
nothing to do with the challenges facing
american families or the robust debates
on substance that can strengthen our
party green for her part responded with
a tweet saying
weak republicans are the real cancer
chief washington correspondent major
garrett joins us now major good morning
to you
what is mitch mcconnell up to here one
of the obligations of leaders in
politics is to take something that looks
complex and actually make it simple
and the simple question mitch mcconnell
is putting before republicans is
is the foundation of our party based on
anti-semitism
911 denialism denialism of mass
shootings
and other conspiracy theories so fringe
so beyond the pale
that they're all they're barely be you
can barely repeat them with any
credibility in any quarter of american
life is that the foundation of the
republican party
mitch mcconnell's sort of putting that
question before the party itself
and members of congress he believes
quite obviously the answer is
no and house republicans have to figure
out how to deal with marjorie taylor
greene
and mitch mcconnell is at least trying
to give them a way to say
this is not the republican party's
present or future but if house
republicans say or do nothing about her
it might be so do you think that
mcconnell's comments
could impact the democratic push to
strip marjorie taylor green of her
committee assignments in the house
well that's going to be something
democrats can and will do on their own
but it certainly doesn't slow them down
it gives them ammunition
and one thing to point out about
congresswoman green she said the problem
with republicans is they only know how
to lose
this is someone who represents a
congressional district in georgia
that's a plus 27 republican district no
democrat there's got more than 30
percent trump won it by 75 percent
she doesn't know anything about running
in a competitive house district let
alone running
in a competitive state mitch mcconnell
does other republicans theoretically do
they should have talked with her about
that as well major is the republican
party still the party of donald trump
i'm thinking of uh
house leader mccarthy visiting former
president trump
in florida last week taking that picture
thumbs up and everything
well of course he is a huge voice in the
republican party and
marjorie taylor green is trying to get
his support publicly for her that hasn't
happened
she said that she has talked to him no
confirmation from former president
trump's office on that
that she supports him no confirmation
from former president trump's office on
that what kevin mccarthy needs
from president trump is to say look
republicans should be unified and
focused on 2020
to admit winning a house majority there
and not
these fringe theories that marjorie
taylor green
likes to talk about all right major
garrett thank you very much and while we
have to say goodbye for this moment our
viewers never have to say goodbye to
major garrett on his podcast the debrief
this week's episode takes a look at
disinformation
very timely thank you